you say you want to buy back how much
money are we talking about here they've
already done 30 billion uh you
considered that a success because I know
you pushed hard for that how much more
well you know I I said it not completely
jokingly that I would see nothing wrong
with him doing aund billion doll tender
offer we you think this company is so
cheap I spoke to Tim Cook uh you know I
I sent him the letter I spoke to him the
other night and uh and you know he
believes the company's very undervalued
just as I do
uh you know I mentioned the buyback to
him and obviously he couldn't say
anything would not committ but is an old
poker player you know just reading the
tea leaves I think they will do a major
buyback that's my guess though and uh
but it's a poker play I throw a lot of
chips in on on that bet and uh it makes
sense because this company I think if
again looking it as
simplistically is it is it is
really on a new Paradigm it is now you
know you keep saying that they have to
keep introducing introducing I I I
really don't think that that is factual
to the extent that you have to keep
doing that in other words people own
this it's not like you know one day you
own a Buick and the next day you want to
buy a you know you you you go buy a
Cadillac what what it is is a sort of an
annuity where you own an ecosystem you
own you know you own the iPad but you
also own the watch and you also own the
the iPhone 6 and you have all your
collection of photographs on it you have
all your music on it and you don't go
away from that when you're used to it
when you're really involved in it and if
you but you do go away and you do get
market share too from say the Samsung
that isn't quite on the same level and
Samsung is a good company and all but
they're making the hardware and Google's
making the software and that's a big
difference when you have one company
doing the whole thing so I think you
know I we analogized that to a horse I I
remember I'm not I'm not a big racing
fan but I love to look at the winners
and when I was younger I I went out to
the OTB to bet on Secretariat and in the
Belmont it ran away with the race by 31
lengths and I think that's what uh Apple
is doing here